let's review how hiv's reverse
transcriptase works
the yellow strand is hiv rna
it's attached to the reverse
transcriptase enzyme reverse
transcriptase uses the host cell
nucleotides it makes dna using hiv rna
as the template and the viral rna is
destroyed in the process
now let's see how azt works here's the
rna and the reverse transcriptase again
the purple pieces are host cell
nucleotides being assembled into a dna
strand
the green molecule is azt
here it's shown next to a thymidine
molecule one of the four nucleotide
bases a t c and g
azt is very similar to thimodine
only one part of the molecule is
different and because they are so
similar reverse transcriptase mistakes
azt for thymodine and incorporates it
into the dna chain
but the difference is crucial because
when azt is incorporated into the dna
chain
the chain cannot be extended and the
process shuts down
when that happens the hiv life cycle is
disrupted
here is a mutant form of reverse
transcriptase that is resistant to azt
it's resistant because its mutant
molecular structure does not allow azt
to be used as a substitute for
thiamidine
azt is therefore rejected
dna synthesis can proceed
and hiv continues to infect the cell